RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK.
Hey there, and welcome to this
week's Android Developer
Office Hours.
It's just the two
of us this week.
Myself, Richard Hyndman, and--
CHRIS BANES: Chris Banes.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Nick's slacking
off on holiday, and
Stephan Linzner is doing a
talk in Germany today.
GDG Munich I'd like to say.
CHRIS BANES: I don't know.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: It
must be GDG Munich
followed by GDG Berlin.
And there's a hackathon in
Berlin on the weekend and then
Droidcon Berlin on Monday
and Tuesday next week.
Ah, Moritz, you going
to be there?
MORITZ: Yup.
Also Droidcon in Berlin.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Excellent
I'll see you there.
I'm heading out for Monday
and Tuesday as well.
MORITZ: Oh, cool.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I've never
actually been to a Berlin
Droidcon before.
I made a few of them,
the UK ones and the
Dutch ones but never--
CHRIS BANES: That's
the original.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: The original.
Probably going to have a nice
new building for it
this year as well.
CHRIS BANES: Awesome.
MORITZ: Yeah, the last one
was not very good.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: The last
one wasn't really--
you can't say that.
You never know who's watching.
MORITZ: Trying to help.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: RICHARD
HYNDMAN: effort.
Anyway, as usual, we'll be
taking about Android
development topics, and we won't
be answering questions
on unreleased features,
things like that.
Also, as usual, Joseppi
has also joined us.
Hey Joseppi, good to see you.
And Yossi of course.
Hey there.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Hi guys.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK.
CHRIS BANES: [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: If you've
got one ready, let's--
CHRIS BANES: First question.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: --jump
straight in.
CHRIS BANES: Let's
do this one.
Cameron from the US has asked,
is the preferred way to do
HTTP calls still have to
use HttpURLConnection?
Because he apparently
seen some flakiness
in some corner cases.
Yes.
So since ICS changed from the
Apache HTTP library-- but the
preferred way to do it is move
from the Apache library to
HttpURLConnection, and that
hasn't changed since.
There's a good blog post by
Jesse Wilson from about two
years ago which tells why and
explains the reasons.
And so yeah, there's not
much-- there's no
update to it really.
That's they way to go forward.
Yeah.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
is the way to go
forward right?
Yeah.
MORITZ: Sorry, I don't want to
have captured the situation,
but I've also got a question
about the URLConnection.
Can I skim in?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Please do.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah sure.
MORITZ: We've got also one
of those corner cases.
And the situation is that when
we do a post request with the
URLConnection and we wait for a
couple of minutes, like four
minutes, and we do the next post
request, the request is
sent twice.
The server receives the request
twice only after those
four minutes.
If we do the next request
immediately,
it's working fine.
But after four minutes, in a
window of like four to six
minutes, it repeats
the request twice.
And after 10 minutes or so
it works fine again.
Is there anything which we
should take care of?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: That's
a really strange one.
Have you looked on Stack
Overflow for that, see if
other people are suffering
from the same issue?
MORITZ: We had the one person
who had the same issue, but
the answers did not
really suffice.
CHRIS BANES: From what I
remember, HttpURLConnection
uses a pool of connections,
so--
I don't know.
Maybe some flaking has
to do with queueing.
It sounds like a bug if
it is doing this.
There's nothing I can
really think of.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Moritz, is it
on a specific API version?
MORITZ: We had it from four to
one app works, and we're not
sure about the lower
version numbers.
CHRIS BANES: The best thing
to do is file a bug on
betandroid.com.
And set me a link if
you can on Google+,
and I'll have a look.
MORITZ: OK.
Also, is there maybe something
related to the radio shutting
down and going into sleep
mode at some point?
Or is that unrelated?
CHRIS BANES: See I'd have
thought you'd have got a
exception back saying, no
internet connection or
[INAUDIBLE]
if that was happening.
So it sounds like there's some
sort of queueing going on
somewhere where it's just--
you've got the connection for
it, but it's not actually
following the connection.
And then the next time it
happens, it queues them off
and sends them all through.
But either way it sounds
like a bug to me.
MORITZ: OK, I will follow up
on you with Stack Overflow.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah,
sounds good.
MORITZ: Thank you.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Does anyone
else from inside the Hangout
have a question?
Can we carry on?
OK.
Someone was asking--
Alex, from Israel is asking,
how to turn off the
auto-translate feature
for comments in
the developer console.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah,
I saw that just--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Interesting.
Why?
Why would you want to?
Do you know all the languages?
This is only something you
see yourself right?
[INAUDIBLE]
auto-translate feature.
I just tried to bring mine up,
but I have to sign into a
different account.
If it's not an obvious option,
then maybe we didn't think
about turning it off.
But strange, usually
it's an opt in.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, usually
it's a one
time thing isn't it?
You put in your natural language
then press the
button, and it also translates
to everything.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yes, I'm going
to log in and try it.
CHRIS BANES: OK.
I'll look at a question.
So this is a good one.
So Scienza--
I don't think I pronounced that
right-- had asked, how do
you in the Google+ app--
the animated GIFs--
so how is it sort of
been able to decode
them and display them.
So if you have a look--
I'm not sure the actual
exact way they do it.
But if you have a look at the
Google+ Settings app in the
settings, at the bottom
there's an open
source library section.
And what they actually
use to decode the GIF
is listed in there.
So it's an open source
class which you can
download and use yourself.
To actually display it, I'm
not entirely sure how
they're doing it.
But I'm guessing there's a
runnable, which updates an
image view or something
like that.
So yeah, really.
But it's not-- actually
no it's probably not.
I know [INAUDIBLE]
supported in the frameworks.
You have to do it yourself.
But that's how you do it.
MALE SPEAKER: Interesting.
CHRIS BANES: Have you found
the translate thing?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah, you can
turn it off on a per comment
basis, so you get no--
JOSEPPI: Probably I
can ask question?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Underneath
the--
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK.
JOSEPPI: Well, as everybody
know, hackers are working too
much on the--
you smile because all worries
on this matter, but this is
very important for us.
Hackers are working on some
place or [? mode ?]
and around the web, but we can
find many, many APK that
install a fake store.
I have developed myself some
sign to check on server site.
So when the fake market store
returns the result--
and this market we
know that they
always returned licensed--
I get the sign [? through ?]
and send to the server and
compare it to the public key
from back server, from
Google panel.
This is correct?
Or do you think that the method
that I am using it's
hard to work around?
To go around?
The sign to check I mean,
it's a good system?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yes.
What I would recommend the most
is to do the check on
your servers if possible, and
then only give access to the
content inside the application
once your server has validated
that the user should have
access to the content.
So if you can pass the signed
message back to your server,
then it means-- when you get to
this level of security, it
means that the hackers have
to individually hack you
application as opposed
to using some generic
hacks that may work--
JOSEPPI: They have to work
especially on the application.
They cannot use the automatic
[INAUDIBLE] software.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Exactly.
So then they're working against
you directly to hack
your application, and then you
have control over the--
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: --applications
to fix the
hacks and--
JOSEPPI: More hard, more
hard, more hard.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah, yeah,
yeah, but this is the hardest
for them to achieve the value of
freeing your application or
making your application free.
If they can make a lot of
applications free with one
hack, then obviously that's
a lot easier for them.
JOSEPPI: But Richard, the
question is the following.
Because to check the license and
then get back the response
et cetera, et cetera, many times
depends on the distance
between our European server and
the final customer that
probably is in Australia, OK?
This takes time in the license
check purchase.
So what is the problem?
The problem is--
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
JOSEPPI: The problem
is that I would
like to store it somewhere.
The first answer of the
licensed check.
So once the licensed check is
approved and I'm sure that the
sign too is fine, I would
like to store somewhere.
OK, next time, don't check the
license again, and almost two,
three second to check
the license.
Is there any, any kind of
storing system that we can use
to save the data safely?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Sure we do.
JOSEPPI: [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
most recently against storing
data on Android.
And you can get to a point
where again, you're in a
position where the hacker
would have to hack your
individual application quite
hard to get access to it.
There's a recent blog post on
the Android developer's blog,
learn how to secure data.
Of course, if the user has route
access, they can get
access to the data.
But then if it's encrypted and
we give you guidelines on how
to encrypt it, then they'd
have to unencrypt it.
And then they've got
to hack your
application to find the key.
And if you use a salt as well,
and you store that salt,
encrypt it as well and you know,
there's a few different
things you can do to make it
harder and harder and harder
for someone to get
access to it.
JOSEPPI: [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Right.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: And if you're
changing the key with each
time someone starts the app,
then it's even harder.
There's a lot of things
you can do.
But we did a blog post on it
recently about the best ways
to secure data on Android.
But of course, if you have a
very dedicated hacker who
really, really wants to get
access to that data, then--
and you know, they've got the
resources to do it, then they
can do it on any system.
It's not an Android issue.
JOSEPPI: Of course.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: It's a
computing issue, right?
JOSEPPI: Of course.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: But just make
it as hard as you can for them
to get access to it.
But have a look at
the blog post.
There's some very good
recommendation for--
and sample code for
quite simple ways
to secure your data.
Which will make it much
harder for hackers.
JOSEPPI: What if you happen to
have the link probably you can
put in chat for me.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Sure.
Yeah, it was like three
posts ago on the
Android developer blog.
CHRIS BANES: Yes, I agree.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I'll
upload that.
CHRIS BANES: It would be on the
first page of the blog.
JOSEPPI: OK, OK, thank you.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I'll try
and find the thing.
CHRIS BANES: So I've
got a question--
Has anyone else got a question
in the chat?
JOSEPPI: If I would
like to share a--
CHRIS BANES: Joseppi's
gone again.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Joseppi?
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Oh,
so he's stuck.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: So the title
of our blog post was, "Using
Cryptography To Store
Credentials Safely On Android.
I haven't got access to a
keyboard, so I won't put it in
the chat, but "Using
Cryptography To Store
Credentials Safely On Android.
Answering--
what was the name of they guy
who had a question about the
developer console.
CHRIS BANES: Alex.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Alex from
Israel's question on disabling
auto-translation, looks like you
can't do it at the moment.
CHRIS BANES: Yossi's replied.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: We are now
showing automated translations
of user review-- you can also
view the user review in your
original language.
You can also set your
language at--
yeah.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah,
there was an
announcement on the dev console--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yes.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: --and you can
only basically set the
translation to which
language--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: You can do
it on a per review basis.
You can see the original
translations, but you can't
turn it off globally for
all translations.
But I'll certainly pass that
back to the Google Play
developer console team
who sit [INAUDIBLE].
And let them know that
you'd like to be able
to turn it off again.
Yup, hey Moritz.
MORITZ: Hi.
When starting an activity, you
have the activity options.
We had the [INAUDIBLE]
video a few days ago, which
shows you how to fade into a
new activity from someplace
or from an image actually.
RICHARD HYNDMAN:
[? It's a mix ?].
CHRIS BANES: That mix.
MORITZ: Exactly.
Last video, and is there
a way to do that for
fragments as well?
CHRIS BANES: Not really.
So you can put custom animations
in, so you can put
set custom animations on the
fragment transaction.
MORITZ: Yep.
CHRIS BANES: So you could,
theoretically, get the view
from the fragment by calling
fragment.getView, and then
hacking an animation
together that will
do something similar.
MORITZ: You would need to
provide an ID for an
animation, so can you create an
animation which has an ID
at runtime?
CHRIS BANES: There's two
versions of methods from what
I remember.
There's one which gives the
resource ID and one that has
an animation object.
MORITZ: No, I think
they both--
there are two methods,
but I think they
both require the ID.
CHRIS BANES: OK.
I'll check that.
In that case I'll--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: I think
you can use the--
to create an object for
animation, then
attach it to the view.
Just a second.
Animations.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
custom animations.
[INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BANES: [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
enter, exit [INAUDIBLE].
YOSSI ELKRIEF: OK,
load animation
from a resource and--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah, I can't
see a way of doing it, you're
right, without using
[INAUDIBLE].
MORITZ: I mean, obviously,
passing in your own custom
animation would probably solve
this as you pointed out.
But the API doesn't
allow it yet.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, I can't
think of a way then.
MORITZ: OK, thanks anyways.
CHRIS BANES: I'll investigate.
Because that's quite an
interesting thing to have a
look at, so--
MORITZ: Most definitely, yeah.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Wait, but if
you have a fragment holder
view, can't you do the
animation on it
when the view changes?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, you
could have a--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: It should be
easier to do that instead of
hacking after the view
is created or
something like that.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Like once
onViewCreated, and then you
load the animation and insert
it to the view back.
MORITZ: But I want to have the
same effect, like you fade up
an image, and then the image is
displayed in full screen.
For example, like in
a gallery, like
you would have it.
So you would need the original
location of the image in the
first fragment and fade it up
to the full-screen fragment.
Like [INAUDIBLE]
does pretty well.
OK.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, I'll
look [INAUDIBLE].
MORITZ: Thanks anyways.
CHRIS BANES: If no one else has
got a question I'll get
[INAUDIBLE]
Moderator.
So--
it's an abbreviated name, Howard
Porkins, I think, from
San Jose in California, has
asked, what's the best way to
check and see if you're
able to commit a
transaction for fragments?
Before being able to
use state loss.
So if you call commit before
and after unsaved instance
[INAUDIBLE], you'll get
an exception back.
So he's asking, what's the best
way to check whether you
are passed that or not.
And if you are, save the
transaction and being able to
sort of commit it later.
So my original thought with
this was, if you want to
commit the transaction later
anyway, why not choose
commitAllowingStateLoss and cut
out the middle section of
the code and just
do it anyway.
But if you do want to handle
it yourself and save the
transaction for later, the best
way to do would be to
save some sort of flag or
variable or something in your
activity, in your save
[INAUDIBLE].
And then reload it on restore
and retrace it and commit it.
JOSEPPI:
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
CHRIS BANES: So yeah.
[INAUDIBLE].
Find a good question?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Nope.
CHRIS BANES: No?
OK.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: WebView
inside a
ScrollView below some TextViews.
ScrollView will always
start from the top of
the WebView by itself.
WebView inside a ScrollView?
Why would you put a ScrollView
inside a ScrollView?
That's going to be tricky.
CHRIS BANES: I don't know.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: He wants to
put a WebView inside a
ScrollView, below
some TextViews.
The ScrollView would always
start from the top of the
WebView making the TextViews
above it go
out of the top page.
I need the WebView to show
some styled HTML content.
Is there any solution?
CHRIS BANES: I think he's
asking for WebView to be
non-scrollable.
Because it wraps.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: If Winkey
Wong has any more--
CHRIS BANES: Is that the name?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
CHRIS BANES: Good name.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I need
more details.
I don't quite understand
the question.
You want a WebView below some
TextViews and the WebView
would always be making the
TextViews above it go out of
the top edge?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: He wants a fixed
TextView on top and then
a WebView--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: But he wants
the whole thing to scroll
together or he wants to make?
Yeah, I think just
try it basically.
It depends what you want
to put in the WebView.
Maybe if it's only text content,
you could use the
TextView underneath and then use
that TextView to turn the
HTML styling on for
that TextView
would be a good option.
Hopefully, that would
work for you.
Try and avoid using a WebView
inside a ScrollView.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: If you are
going to do that, you're going
need to handle the touches
yourself, and then decide
which ones to pass to the
WebView and which to leave at
the ScrollView layer.
And my guess is, you would
just stop the WebView
processing any TouchViews
at all.
So you'd override the touch
handler of the WebView.
CHRIS BANES: I think
that's great what
you said in the reply.
Texts you can actually
handle, simple HTML.
So if things like paragraphs,
and [INAUDIBLE], those sort of
things, they're all handled
quite nicely by TextView.
So the nice-- and there's
a static method called
HTML.fromHTML.
Which will convert your HTML
into a [INAUDIBLE] which can
be displayed by TextView.
And so that's quite a nice
thing, and it will eliminate
the whole scrollable
content within a
scrollable view group.
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
I think we might got
a post on that
recently as well, handling.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: --through
different layers of views.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: What's the best
way to show an action bar
in a DialogFragment?
Tricky?
Yeah, DialogFragments don't
have action bars.
CHRIS BANES: Fragments
aren't supposed to.
Activities are.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Why, are you unnamed?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah,
I'm unnamed.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
All right.
So as Chris says--
[LAUGHTER]
YOSSI ELKRIEF: I was wondering
who has no name.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Why didn't you sign in?
CHRIS BANES: I do.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: You just
changed your [INAUDIBLE] name.
CHRIS BANES: It's my
corp account, so--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK.
Yeah, you can [INAUDIBLE]
yourself.
I'm not quite sure why would
you want an action bar in a
dialogue but--
CHRIS BANES: It's
quite similar.
Because actually, Google+
does this.
So then [INAUDIBLE]
yourself.
There's no easy way that--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Where
is it in Google+?
CHRIS BANES: It feeds on the
phone, you get post.
Oh, there we go.
RICHARD HYNDMAN:
Oh, yes, yeah.
When you're in a post there
is an action bar in a
dialogue for that.
CHRIS BANES: You can
fake it as well.
So you can have an activity
stall as a dialogue and
[INAUDIBLE]
each way.
But it's not really supported
as such so--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
Dialogue.
He doesn't have the dialogue
on top of the dialogue.
Cancel.
CHRIS BANES: Michael from
Austin has asked--
so using BitmapFactory.Options
inSampleSize, so being able to
sample an image [INAUDIBLE]
constrains on a bitmap.
So he's trying to do it in GIF
images, and he's wondering why
it's not working.
So I'd look at [INAUDIBLE], look
at the code and for some
reason or another, it hasn't
been added to the GIF decoder.
I'm not sure entirely
the reasons why.
It might be a restriction on
the GIF decoder we use, but
the option just isn't
even read.
So as it's been there since
version one, I'm guessing it's
a known issue, and there's
just no way to fix it.
I'm not entirely sure.
It needs some more
investigation.
But the issue has been there
in book tracker for about
three years now so
I don't know.
It seems quite a big
one to miss.
I have no more information
than that.
It's just what I've
had [INAUDIBLE].
So other ways around it.
So you could decode the
image yourself.
There are various image loading
libraries in which you
can use which don't
use Android's
built-in image decoder.
So ImageMagick is one, there's
one by Lightbox which you can
use, which includes it's
own GIF decoder.
So you could use them.
Or you could go the hard route,
and then load the
bitmap full size,
then [INAUDIBLE]
bitmap.
But that's [INAUDIBLE].
So the best way would be to
try and do your images in
pings rather than GIFs really.
So sorry, I haven't
got anything
more than that really.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah, why
are you using GIFs?
Joe is asking what are good
ways to do assertions and
debug code in Android.
We want to be able to put a
few assertions in and have
them be easily removed.
Stephan's actually dong a talk
on something very related to
this in Munich tonight.
He would be the guy
to answer it.
He has a lot of information on
this, so maybe we can answer
it in more depth in next week's
office hours when
Stephan's back.
But in the meantime--
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, ProGuard
is pretty good for
this kind of stuff.
So you can set it to strip
out individual methods.
So a good way is, you have
your log.d, log.exception
methods in Android.
You can change your ProGuard
conflict to strip all those
methods out automatically,
which is quite nice.
There's also ways you
can do it around--
so when you build your
[INAUDIBLE], there's
BuildConfig for all that
gets generated.
And that is a variable called
DEBUG, which get's set to true
or false depending on whether
the app has been built in
DEBUG mode or release mode.
And so you can wrap your-- wrap
any sort of assertion or
DEBUG code in one of those
[INAUDIBLE], and then it won't
run on a release.
And if you use ProGuard, the
good thing is that it will
also get stripped out as well.
So--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
size.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK.
I have a special requirement to
get the installation date
of an application which I
installed from Google Play.
I want to get installation date
from Google Play with my
own account.
How do I get that date?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, see when I
read this, I wasn't sure if he
was using an app or trying to
get the dates from an external
kind of service.
So there is no Google Play
API which you can use.
So I took it that it
was from an app.
So PackageInfo has got a lot
of information about
applications, and so you can
get the PackageInfo for
individual apps from--
getPackageManager.
And so once you have the object
for an individual app,
it can give you a lot
of information.
What installed it?
When was it first installed?
There's all sorts.
So yeah, all the information
is there.
There's a variable called first
installed dates, which
will tell you when it
was first installed.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Has anyone in
the chat seen any interesting
Android news this week they
want to talk about?
Anything we can talk about
that's come up that is.
What's been going on this week
in the Android land?
It's been a quiet week.
CHRIS BANES: It's been
a quiet week.
MORITZ: I think just today, we
had the new developer console
stats, and they were
[? tuned ?]--
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
MORITZ: --5%.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Switch the
Android dashboards on the
developer console to show the
stats based on active users of
the Play store as opposed to
active Android devices.
So Android devices hit
two of our servers.
They do check-ins and
they also do--
yeah, when people use
the Play store.
And we believe that the Play
store stats are more relevant
for Android app developers.
You want to see the users who
will be downloading your
applications, and those stats
are also more favorable in
terms of Ice Cream Sandwich and
Jelly Bean hitting close
to 60% of the market together
on the Play store stats.
So if you are looking at
building an Android
application, API 10 and upwards
is like over 90% now.
And API 13 and upwards
is kind of 60%.
So it's--
CHRIS BANES: Really.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: 58.
CHRIS BANES: 54 was it?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Was it?
OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
somewhere.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Close enough.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: My
bad [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, but we are
seeing more and more apps
going ICS upwards
now, which is--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yes.
It can save you a lot of
development time just doing it
once using all the latest
features and doing it all
[INAUDIBLE].
It can definitely be worth--
especially, if you think in six
to 12 months time, all the
effort you're putting in to
doing the Gingerbread versions
will be, for the most part,
not that relevant.
Has anyone pre-orderd a Galaxy
S4 or an HTC One yet?
I'm not sure you can
order an S4 yet.
Has anyone played with
an HTC One or an S4?
Anybody seen any of
these devices?
Mythical devices?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No, not yet.
MORITZ: Yeah, I've played
with the One.
Quite nice.
It's very cool.
I like the speakers.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: The speakers?
MORITZ: They're pretty
loud actually.
Good for consuming snippets
of videos.
It's pretty cool.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Would you
consider getting one?
MORITZ: Well, it's not the
Android, so it's hard to
recommend for me.
But for somebody else?
Yeah maybe.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Interesting.
MORITZ: I most like
it actually.
It's expensive though.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah,
S4's going to be
expensive as well, right?
Both of these are
top end devices.
I haven't played with either
of them yet, I'm looking
forward to trying them out.
Maybe, Samsung will turn
up a Droidcon Berlin.
[INAUDIBLE]
UK last year.
MORITZ: The One is
really solid.
It's pretty awesome
to touch it.
It's really cool.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: HTC has that
build quality thing down.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah the
hardware is--
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
CHRIS BANES: --really good.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: People
have said that that
screen's just amazing.
How it would ride up on the
surface of the phone, and very
high definition.
Quite looking forward to that.
MORITZ: I'm not so sure
about the Blinkfeed.
What's it called?
The very first home screen
thing, which you always have
by default.
I'm not sure that's really
something I would like to use.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I didn't
really spot that.
MORITZ: A bit strange.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I sort of
ignored all those things.
MORITZ: And also, I found it
interesting, the very first
thing you do on the device, you
unlock it, and you swipe
away at the clock And
this is a bit laggy.
And the very first impression
you get, it lags.
And that's very strange.
The other stuff doesn't lag,
but the unlocking, swiping
away at the phone, the clock,
that's strange.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I wonder
if that's a
power management issue.
When it's locked, they're
keeping the power rate down.
And then you swipe, it's
ramping up those--
CHRIS BANES: Yeah,
[? the CP Unit ?].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: --300
processes or
whatever it's got.
MORITZ: Possibly, yeah.
Yeah, I mean the [INAUDIBLE].
Is that right?
That's pretty awesome
[INAUDIBLE].
I love it.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
OK, actionlauncher155--
says Yossi, go actionlauncher.
We've got one question left
in the Moderator.
Is it advisable for an app to
rely on shared preferences.
Yeah, yeah.
Does it use XML to store
the data internally?
I'm developing an app which
stores data in a
raw XML file privately.
Few devices throw an end of
file exception when the
battery is removed.
What may be the reason.
Yeah, I would definitely go
for shared preferences.
CHRIS BANES: Well, it depends
on his [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Well,
[INAUDIBLE] text file stuff.
CHRIS BANES: If you're all
storing raw XML yourself, I
wouldn't use a shared
preference.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I see.
You think he's storing--
I though he meant he's using
XML to store the data.
But you're right.
He wants--
he's storing his data
in a raw XML file.
Is he storing XML data
or is he storing raw?
CHRIS BANES: See,
I don't know.
Shared preferences are--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: It's
a good point.
CHRIS BANES: --
[INAUDIBLE]
store.
So if you're storing data where
you have it, sort of key
value form then yeah, shared
preferences is great.
But if you're storing anything
more complex and you need
compound objects or whatever,
JSON or an XML format is
probably a good way to go.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Or you
could use stORM.
CHRIS BANES: Or you
RICHARD HYNDMAN: David Chandler,
our own David
Chandler, has been working
on an ORM for
Android called stORM.
So you could just stash your
objects away nicely.
And it does all your data
access objects for you
[INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BANES: One final
thing actually.
You mentioned using an object
output stream and that's using
serialization, which
is generally a
bad thing on Android.
You should be using
[INAUDIBLE]
objects, and always output into
some sort of text, XML or
JSON if you're going to file.
Serialization is slow, so
that's my word on that.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Have you
looked at stylus events?
There was one last question
there that was put at the end.
Stylus events are supported
since ICS.
Is it possible to subscribe
for events when the user
unplugs the stylus
from the device.
It's a very strange--
CHRIS BANES: So they just
want a system sort
of call backer of--
So stylus events come through
as mouse events.
[INAUDIBLE]
views, so--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: I don't think
we have a concept of it,
stylus being plugged in
and unplugged though.
You just get the
events through.
CHRIS BANES: You just
get the up and down.
That's pretty much it.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
OK, we're about done.
Does anyone else in the Hangout
have any questions
before we call it quits
for this week?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No, just wanted
to point out that the Android
developer event shows that the
time is 5:00 PM instead of
4:00 PM for Israel.
It an hour difference.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Thank
you Yossi.
What for this show today?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
I just saw it right now.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Cheers.
OK, we'll get that resolved.
That's because the US changed
time zone two weeks ago, and
we were two weeks behind.
And they actually set
our shows up for us.
They haven't noticed that we've
caught up on Saturday
with our time zones.
Maybe I'll pop back on in an
hour and apologize to the
people who are trying
to join us then.
Thanks very much for everyone
who joined us today.
We'll be back at the same time
next week for more Android
developer questions.
CHRIS BANES: Cheers guys.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Bye guys.
Cheers.
JOSEPPI: --guys.